where are you
I look everywhere and ask myself
it's just a nightmare
tell me my favorite girl to photograph
well my favorite girl
[Music]
what inspires you life are you uh fed up
with celebrity life I never liked
celebrity culture
[Music]
do you know how many copies my book sold
not what I want don't touch me I love
you
[Music]
aren't you afraid that people are gonna
see what a fraud you are
you scared look at me
I can't photograph your soul
we don't exist
hello are you wondering where Matilda is
meet me at the hotel Vista tide where's
Matilda
I've lost something something or someone
he's here to learn he fights a childhood
what comes to mind
I don't need to be analyzed right now
because last time you saw her Shadow and
light light and Shadow can I have your
attention
take me to her
is she dead darkness is extinguishes
I don't know what's real
you know what I see
here I don't know what to believe I hear
things I'm beginning to forget the shape
of your face
where are you
I see the truth